the American poet Carl Sandburg once
wrote the moon is a friend for the
lonesome to talk to this is a day in the
life of a lonely empty City 6:20 a.m.
the first rays of Sun over New York
seven o'clock in the morning the
normally bustling Harlem is hushed
the 125th Street subway station at 7:45
a.m. that the rumble of the 1 train cuts
through the eerie stillness
a few minutes after 8:00 a.m. Times
Square the bright lights but not a soul
to see them 7th Avenue in midtown
Manhattan this is morning rush hour this
is New York suspended in time by a
silent and deadly virus a siren from an
ambulance off in the distance 140 in the
afternoon The Surreal shutdown of the
city is hard on everyone especially the
elderly many of whom are alone
2:46 p.m. and here it's busy because
there's a hospital people linger outside
maybe waiting for word on a loved one
inside at 4:15 p.m. a few signs of life
in this residential neighborhood in
Brooklyn for the essential workers life
is hard at 6:00 p.m. there is no rush to
get home from the office everyone is
home by early evening more people
secluded in their apartments all day
begin to come out masks are required
this is a new normal as another day
draws to a close in a paralyzed city a
reminder that New York will be back
but the vibrant busy city that never
sleeps a return to that might take a
while gabe rose ando al jazeera New York